jean pascal a dit dans les locaux de tv
soixante dix huit lecteurs du film tout
simplement noir est venu tourner une
séquence de la saison 2 de sa série
craignos sur notre plateau au programme
de cette scène enregistré ce vendredi 24
juillet qui sera diffusée sur la
plateforme de france tv un débat
télévisé et on est très humoristique
comme la série craignos on essaye de
parler un peu d'actualité avec un axe
décalé dans la série craignos et donc on
essaye de tout passer tous les sujets au
crible la télévision la religion la
police tout ça et tout est là on est
dans une séquence de télévision qu'on a
poussé un peu on va dire dans cette
scène en plus de gens parce qu'elle a
dit on retrouve une personnalité bien
connue du grand public sébastien thoen
animateur depuis de nombreuses années
sur canal+ il joue justement aujourd'hui
le rôle d'un présentateur
ça m'a fait marrer puis gip l'on se
connaisse un petit peu comme ça il
m'avait dit un jour je te ferai tourner
remarque que nos gens m'ont dit ça tu
sais comment c'est le milieu qui te
rappellent jamais parce que t'es pas
assez bon pas assez connus t'as pas
assez de followers sur instagram mais jp
m'a rappelé et puis il m'a proposé ce
rôle de présentateur et ça m'a fait
marrer et ça s'est plutôt bien passé
j'espère que ça va vous plaire c'est
c'est sur france 2 c'est pas sur canal
ça fait chier mais c'est comme ça
sébastien thoen n'est pas le seul à
rejoindre le casting pour cette nouvelle
saison total soixante douze comédiens
participeront à l'aventuré pour répondre
à sa nouvelle durée les épisodes passe
de 13 à 26 minutes pour cette saison du
un défi d'écriture
parce que le scénario fait près de 300
pages il a fallu six sept mois jean
pascal et à kamel guerra son coauteur
pour pour en arriver à bout
plusieurs versions et ouais un défi raid
déjà deux au niveau de l'écriture et en
termes de production bas on passait de
la saison une à 84 minutes elle à 7 230
4 minutes
la diffusion des premiers épisodes de
cette saison des programmés d'ici début
février 2021